matt hancock what are you announcing
this evening well
we're constantly vigilant and
we've been looking at the data and
unfortunately we've seen across parts of
northern england
an increase in the number of cases of
coronavirus so
today i held a meeting of the
government's gold committee
and working with local leaders including
for instance
andy burnham the mayor of greater
manchester we've decided
that we need to take action across
greater manchester
east lancashire and parts of west
yorkshire
so from midnight to night we are
banning households meeting up
indoors we take this action with a heavy
heart
but unfortunately it's necessary because
we've seen that households meeting up
and
a lack of social distancing is one of
the causes of this rising rate of
coronavirus
and we'll do whatever is necessary to
keep the country safe
[Music]
we should explain the reasons why which
way for that helicopter to go
but you were explaining why you've taken
this this action
across parts of northern england we've
seen a
an increase in the rates of coronavirus
and
one of the reasons for that increase is
that we've seen
households gathering and not abiding by
the social distancing rules
and that means that we've had to take
the decision
to to ban households meeting together
indoors in order to try to stop the
spread of this virus because
we'll do whatever is necessary to keep
the country safe
today what is your message to people
especially the north
of england that might be worried we are
heading for a second peak
or the government are losing control
well we can see a second peak
coming in parts of europe that's why
we've taken the some of the action we've
had too for instance in
spain and we're absolutely determined to
keep people
safe here so we'll take the action that
is necessary
in order to do that and for instance the
action that we've taken today
across parts of northern england where
we can see that increase in the number
of
cases is all about keeping people safe
and what we've seen is that one of the
causes of this increase
is households gathering together
ignoring the social distancing rules
so we're having to bring in firm action
and
say that two households cannot meet
indoors
because that way we can help
to stop the spread of the virus and
we've got to bring this in
straight away because we can see those
numbers increasing
and we need to keep a control of this
virus